this kind of behavior that's going on
smith college is illiberal it is it is
a very dogmatic and rigid ideology
and it's authoritarianism
and welcome to trigonometry i'm francis
foster
i'm constantine kitchen and this is a
show for you if you want honest
conversations
with fascinating people our brilliant
guest today is a lifelong liberal who's
just resigned from
smith college in the united states
calling it a racially hostile
environment
jody shaw welcome to trigonometry thank
you so much for having me
constantine and francis it is great to
have you
on the show uh i mentioned very briefly
your story but there'll be a lot of
people
who might have heard about your case and
uh but won't necessarily know anything
about you so why don't you give us
a little background into who are you how
are you where you are what has been the
journey through life that leads you
here sitting talking to us
well that's a lot since i'm almost 50
years old
let me try to break it down for you um
i am a lifelong liberal
that is true and i actually graduated
from smith college in 1993
and then i spent some time traveling and
you know more of an artistic kind of
person and then i became a professional
musician
i lived in new york city for many years
and then i had children
and life changed a bit and i you know i
needed a job that
was uh you know not hustling at 2 am
and hustling for money so i decided to
become a librarian
and i was a children's librarian for a
couple of years and then i moved
out of the city i wanted more space and
so that's what brought me to northampton
originally which is where smith college
is located and
i'd always remembered smith as this just
really
idyllic amazing
place i mean the town too northampton
just super
liberal like uber liberal and i thought
wow that would be a great place to raise
my kids and
you know it'll be just so wonderful
and i was overjoyed to land a position
in the smith college libraries smith had
always been like
my secret dream place to work
and so um i started working in the
libraries
and while i was working there there was
an incident on campus
about a year into my position it was i
was in a temporary position
but i was up for a permanent position
and then while i was there there was an
incident
and this incident it involved a black
student and a white custodian
and the college's response to that
really kind of changed things in my mind
on campus and i've confirmed with
this with other people who have been at
smith longer it really
um the college even though the in
the incident the black student accused
the white a custodian of engaging in
racially motivated behavior against her
and uh the college immediately she was
eating lunch somewhere
and was and the white person said you
look out of place or something
is that what happened yeah well as of
course there's a lot more to the story
i mean this was during the summer and
this is a house on campus
that um students are able to live on
campus in the summer
but there's there's special there's
certain houses that they live in
and this was not one of them and there's
certain places where students are
supposed to eat and this house was not
one of them
this house was actually being used as
many houses are on campus during the
summer
for another and outside program
and this house in particular was being
used for a summer camp
for young children age five and over and
and be
and and it wasn't being used to house
them it was just being used to feed them
it was just like lunch
i think i'm not sure if it was breakfast
too so
it was only being used for that purpose
and because it was children using the
house all of the adults
in the house were also had background
checks naturally
and so this clearly this this was not
the house where the student should have
been eating
so that part of the story really got
lost at the time
um because it was touted as a common
area on campus and
you know why am i not allowed to be in a
common area it's like and then the
president came out and said yeah
students are allowed in all
parts on campus that's not technically
true
not during the summer and so in spite of
that fact the student went into this
house
and the dining staff person who was
working there knew the student
and said oh hey you know hey so-and-so
um i didn't know you were in this camp
you know they kind of said something
because even
even before this the staff are somewhat
reluctant
to approach students um to enforce rules
because uh the college has demonstrated
even prior to this that they
they're kind of hesitant to back up the
staff so if the staff try to enforce a
state law like
you need to put shoes on in the dining
room sometimes that can
backfire on them and the student will
accuse them of engaging in
you know abusive behavior or even
racially motivated behavior so the staff
are already a little tentative
so on this day the student came in and
the staff member said i didn't know you
were in this house
and the student i didn't know you were
in this camp
and the student said yeah and flashed
her id
and um the staff member allowed her to
eat there because the staff member
didn't want to
cause any conflict or problems and then
the student took the food and went into
the
living room which nobody was using not
even the summer camp and
late proceeded to lie down on a couch
and i think she was looking at an ipad
or something
a custodian in his 60s whose heart of
who has bad eyesight and i don't he
wasn't wearing his glasses at the time
looked through this door i mean this was
there's so many details to this which
the the details alone if you know them
plus combined with the investigative
report which was 170 pages
of documents it really makes a hard hard
case for anyone to argue that this was
racially motivated
and these are staff long-time staff
members who have worked on a campus
which is about half
a white and half students of color
they've worked with students of color
you know for years and years and years
and years with no like this person
didn't never had a problem before
clearly this person was out of place
this person was out of place was
unexpected
um and so the staff did what they were
told which is if you see something
no matter what it is if you feel like
something's out of place please call
the campus police who are unarmed and
that's what the custodian did
and the student later that evening and
everything seemed fine the initial she
videotaped the interactions
the the campus police officer who
responded actually recognized her as a
student you know and it was a
friendly exchange from what i can tell
and then
but later that night the student made a
facebook post
this facebook post is what the college
responded to i mean the college
really went overboard profuse apologies
um insinuating that it was a racial
incident before ever investigating any
of the
facts and putting into place all these
like
announcing its intention to put into
place anti-bias
training for staff not for faculty for
staff
um and all these other programs and
initiatives and committees and so on and
so forth and this was all before they
even did an investigation
and so even after the investigation
found there was
clearly no ra evidence of racial bias
the college continued to uphold this
narrative
that there was there's horrible racism
on smith campus and we had we need all
these programs
and um the tragedy the real tragedy of
this is is one
it really um created a
uh a real rift between staff and
students because now staff are
very they they've seen what what's
happened and they're very afraid because
because what happened was the student
didn't know who called
she couldn't identify the person who
called campus police on her and she was
determined that that that individual
being publicly named
and so she went through the campus
directory and pulled out two other
people
one of them actually was the dining
staff worker without her stay there she
put
she put her picture in her name and the
picture and name of another custodian
who wasn't even there at the time
on her facebook page and said here are
the people who did this to me
and those people really suffered
material harm as a consequence it was
just
it's outlined in new york times article
that just came out yesterday
as did the responding police officer who
was terminated eight months later
now we don't know the exact conditions
of this termination but
this is a long-standing 35-year employee
with a spotless record
a beloved fixture of campus
and so when the staff the other staff
see all this happening
it this creates a hostile work
environment
so it's against this backdrop
that individual acts of racism
occurred to me so it's we already have a
hostile work environment and it's very
racially
tense we've created a tense environment
at this point not we smith college
um so that's where my story kind of
unfolds it's like
against all this context and that's why
it's kind of a complicated story because
you know in people
there there was a rap involved
there was a rap i um i you know i'm a
musician as i explained and um
i was tasked to do a huge performance in
front of sick
and engaging orientation from 600
first-year students
it had to be wild and crazy and
um how do you convey what is otherwise
very boring information
you do a wrap obviously so
so that's definitely what i would have
done yeah isn't it right
so it was just obvious you know so um i
worked on this rap for
you for months i mean it's a huge it's
not just me doing a rap there's
musicians and
live musicians there's it's just an
event for 600 people in an auditorium
there was sound people
lights uh i needed the wi-fi repeaters
and
there was it was so much logistics and
this incident happened
around a month before the the
orientation my presentation was to take
place
and i was told less than a week before
the presentation you can't do
the rap and so i said well why because
you're white
and it might be viewed as cultural
appropriation and they
um my supervisor cited the incident
between the student and the custodian as
the reason
and remember this is before the
investigation had started so that was
the first thing that happened
jody before you go any further with the
story itself which i really want to get
into
we started by introducing you as a
self-described lifelong liberal
uh and by the way for our british
audience in america when they say
liberal generally they mean left-wing
it's a sort of weird
difference in language between the two
countries but um
as a lifelong lefty if we're liberal
lefty if we might put it that way
did you not agree automatically with
this way of looking at things that as a
white person you shouldn't be
doing raps because it's cultural
appropriation
well it's that's it that's a good
question um i
when i when you know obviously my first
year at smith they were talking about
these things they were talking about
systemic reason they're talking about
whiteness and i was on board
and i thought you know i'm not an
academic
that you know they must know if there's
this thing called systemic racism even
though i'm not
really clear on what that means or i
can't really see any
evidence of that like i understand what
racist
behavior is like observable acts of
racism when somebody does something or
deny somebody an opportunity because of
their race
clearly i know what that is but this
systemic racism i'm not
a little fuzzy on what that is and the
college didn't really explain it fully
but i trusted them
i thought this is an elite institution
there
it's an academic institution they must
know and i was on board
and so even when this incident happened
i remember i sent an email to somebody
and i said
isn't this horrible you know this poor
student
who's just eating while black and so
then but then the incident happened to
me with the rap so where you can't do
this because you're white and i was
really confused because i thought
clearly
this counts as racial discrimination and
yet it was done
so unhesitatingly and
um without any memorialized in an email
and even went up to the dean of
libraries and she said no yeah you can't
do this
i'm backing this up and i thought
is this discrimination
i wasn't i was like i wasn't sure and
then i thought maybe i'm a racist for
thinking this is discrimination for
thinking discrimination against me based
on
my skin color is discrimination it was
really weird it was like this
horrible turmoil in my head and clearly
it would have been such a coup for my
uh resume to pull this off in a
successful manner
in a way that was non-cringe-worthy and
and very unsuccessful you know effective
and i wasn't able to do that and i
thought well
should i report this or you know and
i ended up withdrawing from a job i was
applying for um
because i just felt so bad about all of
it and i didn't
and i felt like you know i don't want to
be in this environment like this feels
very
weird and i i feel it felt horrible
and i felt humiliated too because i felt
like gee am i racist because i thought
to do this like
and now everybody knows how racist and
cult like i'm culturally appropriating
everything like now the whole campus
knows and
um it was very confusing and i thought
for sure if i filed a complaint that i
would never get
hired at smithcot like i would never get
a permanent job there
um because everybody would know that a
white person had filed a complaint
and so i it was a horrible time for me
and i agonized over it and i ended up
just
leaving the libraries and taking a
different position
and when i ended up when more things
happened and i ended up
going to file a complaint one of the
first things i was asked
by the officer who is in charge of
compliance with
the eeo which is the equal employment
opportunity commission
um in the states it's like this um
administrative procedure for ensuring
compliance with i believe the civil
rights act like title vi
title v title ix of the civil rights act
when i went to her to talk about fine
complaint one of the first things she
asked me was
do you believe in white privilege
so that was um that was kind of like
my fears were founded like my my com i'm
not really supposed to be doing this
because i'm white
and then she made other comments like
the civil rights act was created to
protect traditionally marginalized
groups of people and i interpreted that
to me not me because i'm white and she
said
she didn't have experience in this area
and i said what do you mean and she said
well because you're white
so there were three those were three
very clear
comments that told me i proceeded with
the complaint but
it was clear that there was there were
much different rules
for me as a white person and that's
justified
by this critical theory
which posits that my position because of
my
status and that that gets assigned to me
as a white person society i have
too much power to ever
truly be discriminated against or suffer
from discrimination
and jody i'm listening to this
and i'm struggling to get my head around
just how ridiculous this all sounds
but this kind of what was this like this
when you started
or was it a slow creep where you know
you know you start with things like you
know
diversity quotas blah blah blah and then
it went into
a ver well you're white therefore x y
and z
well i think it went into hyper dr i
think it was already kind of there
and then it went to hyperdrive after the
july 31st after the incident between the
black student the white custodian like
the campus went into overdrive
with all these initiatives and programs
and then and when was this
jody what what so what time and date was
it
as in what year was it all the rest of
it so it was um
2018. oh wow okay like from
august 2018 and then during the time
there until may 2020
we were in this kind of hyperdrive you
know about race and whiteness
and white privilege and then i filed my
complaint in may
my final complaint in may 2020 good
timing
i know right and then
as soon as i found my complaint george
floyd was murdered
and blm became very active and we were
in the midst of a global pandemic
under wound staff we're told you might
get furloughed and by the way when
we're making our financial decisions at
you know
one of our priorities is our social
justice education programs so
um it was
i mean talk about hyperdrive it went to
hyper hyper hyper like hyper
squared um that summer so i filed this
complaint and then it got
worse i mean we were getting emails like
i i got an email from my director like
inviting just to the white people in the
department like
i'm inviting all of us white people to
meet to talk about how we can support
our colleagues of color i got an email
i believe from the president saying
white people are especially responsible
for
dismantling racism or systemic racism
just
more of the white white white whiteness
rhetoric
and i started becoming a little more
assertive or a little more aggressive at
that point
and i started sending emails and asking
for definitions because clearly we were
we were using different dictionaries at
this point i i by this point i
well understood that my definition of
racism was not consistent with
um smith college's definition and nor
was my definition of what i think of
with equity and inclu or especially
inclusion
um so i started asking for definitions
and i wasn't able to get those instead i
got like
referred to ebay max kennedy's book i
got um sent an essay called
me and white supremacy um
he's one of my favorites as well
it's a classic it's a nice balanced
reading list it's what you want a little
bit of everything
yeah it's a classic it's
[Laughter]
yeah so it just got worse i couldn't
believe it i was like oh my gosh i just
found this complaint
and it's just like and so
yeah it was it was a rough time
to be a known ad not agitator but a
person
is in within my department who started
questioning this stuff
in this climate was very difficult
i can imagine and then as it progressed
uh
i read the letter that you wrote you you
put you said that your position became
more and more untenable
can you go into a little bit of what
that involved in how you were made to
feel etc
yeah so there was
there were some things that happened um
it was a
very you have to understand more context
every
everything's about context right and
that's why simply reducing people to
skin color makes
no sense because there's so much context
involved in life
right i mean everything absolutely you
know as comedians everything's context
so we were in the middle of a global
pandemic
so in march we were all sent home
we were all sent home we were all
working suddenly remotely there were no
processes you know all of these
yearly processes the well-established
communication channels and workflows
were completely interrupted and we had
nothing we had to rebuild
it was so very confusing nobody knew
what was going on we weren't sure if the
college was gonna
i mean the students were sent home we
were trying to get them home i mean i
was working at the residence life
department at the time so like
we were trying to get these students
home and they couldn't get flights
because everything was shut down it was
complete pandemonium
and so during this summer
it got worse because the race stuff kept
coming at us even in spite of all this
i mean i couldn't believe it it was
almost like that was the priority
over all of this other mess that was
happening
you know through no no fault of smith
that there was a global pandemic but i
just couldn't believe that they were
still pushing that this was the
biggest priority and they they issued
this document called toward racial
justice at smith
which then had further outlined further
initiatives
including something about equity
um being tied to perform like pay
it was like something about pay we're
going to be evaluating pay structures
according to
registers of identity and i thought well
that sounds reasonable
yeah i'm from the soviet union we tried
it and it worked out
fantastically well you're from where
from the soviet union that's where i was
born
oh my gosh yeah
wow i would love to hear about your
experience there
yeah uh well do you talk about it let's
just
let's just sum it up by saying uh we
tried some something very similar
and the results were terrific so
let's just um yeah
you know from each according to his
ability and to each nothing
that's how that works
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website
well if you do then easy dns are the
company for you
easy dns is the perfect domain name
registrar provider and web host for you
they have a track record
of standing up for their clients whether
it be council culture
d platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies
he knows a bit about that so will you in
a second easy dns of
rock-solid network infrastructure and
incredible customer support
they're in your corner no matter what
the world throws at you
unless it's your ex-girlfriend in which
case you're on your own you'd know about
that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns
right now all you've got to do is head
over to easydns.com
forward slash triggered and use our
promo code
which is of course triggered as well and
you will get 50
off the initial purchase sign up for
their newsletter
access of easy that tells you everything
you need to know
about technology privacy and censorship
you know you're handling it very well
you know people won't realize this
but you are in the middle of a new storm
right now there's articles about you
uh people are talking about the issue
and it seems like you
you you know whatever comes out of this
you will hopefully be landing on your
feet but i imagine
it's not been easy and probably the time
that you spend there particularly before
you decided to start speaking up
would you would have felt a bit you know
discombo
not a bit a lot discombobulated and sort
of out of place and
you know do i i imagine that for someone
like you
who's who's had these liberal lefty
views your whole life this must have
been kind of
shattering to your whole identity in
some way
yeah that's the thing i mean i did i
felt very alone
i mean of course there was whispering in
hallways i mean i was not the only one
feeling this um but nobody ever would
talk about it and all out loud in a
meeting
i felt very isolated um
and i felt you feel like an orphan like
like a political orphan really and there
was like a strong
pull um not before i made the video but
after i made the video
from conserve really good people
on the right um and
which but i
and and even a lot of people approached
me said i used to be liberal now i'm on
the right and the thing is like i think
it's
i made a decision early on to kind of
stand my ground
that this is illiberal and this kind of
behavior that's going on smith college
is illiberal
it is it is a very dogmatic and rigid
ideology and it's authoritarianism
and i decided i'm i'm a liberal i
you know i my and when talking about
policy i very much am a liberal like
financial policy
social policies i'm i'm a liberal so i'm
not going to get pushed out i'm not
going to get pushed out of the left i
i think this idea truly this this
ideology um needs to be put in its place
and uh i think it's
really important in the states you know
we're so i imagine they're
there as well i think i know there as
well um
very so polarized and i think that
it's almost a luxury to have political
ideals or to have pop you know to be
still having policy debates
in the face of authoritarianism when
authoritarianism comes to town
no matter what side it comes from like
we know it came from the left this time
um it doesn't matter what side it came
from it doesn't it's here
now it's here now and so it's like
being able to still like say well i'm a
liberal arm on the right it's almost
like that's a luxury of a functioning
democracy
to be able to have those arguments we're
not even like talking about we're not
even talking to each other anymore we're
not
i don't think we are a truly functioning
democracy and i don't mean perfectly
functioning but i mean
i'm willing to set aside my
strongly held viewpoints on certain
policy issues and and
social issues in order to band arms
with people and walk into this together
because it's going to take
a lot of us i think and so
i don't know i i feel like it's
important for us to try to
i think it's going to take all of us and
that's what this
that's what authoritarianism does it
makes especially people on the left like
so afraid of being aligned with the
right
or seen or be guilt by association and
i get that fear because so many on the
left just immediately write
like you off say er very early on after
you made the video i went on tucker
carlson and
i don't know if you know tucker been on
the show it was
very helpful to my left-wing credentials
yes exactly so i mean your man the
message doesn't change but you're seeing
the tucker and it's like
that that stuff really bothers me
because
i just think it's so it's so shallow it
feels so shallow to me
but it's it's a reality um i know but
that's part of how i think this
authoritarianism
works i think it's like keeping us
especially on the left i mean there's
just so much fear people on the right
like
they they know this has been going on
for a long time a lot of them are like i
i saw this 10 years ago
and and or like people like you who
who've come from uh
you know communist regimes
um really i've had a lot of contact with
with people like you constantine who are
like holy like
alarm bells alarm bells alarm bells
and um it's really the people on the
left that
uh need to they need to i don't know
we need to get some moral courage here
folks
we really need to
i don't know it doesn't have to be
making a video like i did but we got to
do something because
this is consuming us and
um it could it it's
consumed smith college and it
made my life really really difficult
it's very hard there's a special kind of
psychic damage that occurs
when you're living in this kind of
working this kind of environment in
which you're lying to yourself
and because you have to because if you
don't
it's like you have to convince yourself
that it's okay it's like a paramorality
um and it it's that
that's not only damaging to yourself but
it kind of it
disables something in us it undermines
this morality in us
that we need to connect with others
authentically
and i think when we're not able to
connect with others authentically when
we
get dehumanized which i think is what's
happening or we dehumanize others
then we're capable of doing very bad
things to each other
that's a very very powerful point
because you use the you see the words
that people use
against people you know not only like
you but against us so people who think
differently and it is dehumanizing
one thing that i really want to ask is
why
has the universities and particularly
the universities in america
provided such rich fertile soil for this
kind of nonsense
um i think it's where this
i don't know you know there's a lot of
theories about that i'm not i'm not an
academic but
i think michelle foucault has something
to do with it
they keep saying that that that's what
i've heard um
and i even heard somebody said you know
it was just a just
a kind of he developed this whole other
moral universe to kind of justify
his lifestyle basically which is kind of
this
uh i get the sense that it was somewhat
hedonistic
uh lifestyle like everything's relative
and you know
there's no absolutes or no objective
truth and therefore there's no morale
real morality it's everything subjective
um
which is astonishing i mean if that's
true that
somebody you know who just simply
justifying a lifestyle of like not
really having
any objective morals has now spread
rampantly
um throughout society but as far as why
you know
the colleges i mean i don't know you'd
have to ask an academic about that
like the marxist cultural marxism or
racist
struggle as opposed to class struggle
all that um
well we've talked about that plenty on
the show but yeah it's interesting i
didn't know anything about foucault's
personal life but it sort of makes sense
now
i'm not cheating on you darling it's
just an alternative lifestyle
it is right like is this bad is this
good we don't know
we don't know and let's not ask any
questions yeah so let's just carry on
and make dinner please she's the third
one this month anyway
monogamy is a power is is oppressive
exactly and yeah i couldn't agree with
you more there all of a sudden
but um but listen let me ask you this
because i think
this is a question that some of your
detractors might be keen
to hear and i wanted to give you a
chance to address it in in a in a
non-hostile environment
we because by look there's a lot of
people
who are like you who are in institutions
which have become
completely captured by this mindset who
are constantly hearing about
toxic whiteness toxic masculinity all
this sort of stuff
but they don't speak out and it strikes
me that you've been
you know quite bold and courageous in in
speaking out against it
have you been radicalized into this
somehow have you been
secretly watching i don't know jordan
peterson on the sly
or or what or what whatever whatever it
is that people apparently get radical
how did you summon up the the fortitude
to start actually taking action on this
um jordan pearson was involved
no i mean i became interested in i don't
know how i became interested in jordan
peterson but i haven't listened to him
that much it was a few years
ago he said something that really struck
me about
not lying about telling the truth and
about how much it hurts when you don't
tell the truth how much you damage you
cost yourself
and i thought i think because i was
really hurting i think this was when i
was hurting at smith and i thought
i think that's why i think it's because
i'm lying to myself like i'm
str i'm not um and so yeah
i did watch some jordan peterson um and
i did start seeking out
alternative um viewpoints
because that part is
i think that part's critical because
remember when i when
they say oh you can't do the rap i was
like is this discriminating i don't know
am i racist like because you get told
like if you resist
this these ideas then then somehow
you're that's your white fragility and
that's
are you seeking to uphold this power
structure which is white supremacist so
in other words it's
a form of racism right it's you're doing
something bad
and so like that little voice that tells
you something's wrong something's wrong
you try to like squelch it
and that's so damaging um
and so i had to validate
that myself in some way and i i had to
find like know for sure that i'm not
crazy and i'm not racist
and so in order to do that i had to kind
of get outside the bubble a little bit
and um seek and and go places where oh
my god no good liberals supposed to go
you know that's what i because i've been
in this bubble telling me oh my god like
you can't that person's white suprema
and i found out wow jordan peterson's
not a sexist
misogynistic person he's actually really
good
person and really thoughtful and like he
really thinks about this stuff a lot and
he's very concerned and
that's when i started when i started
getting validated
then i started getting stronger and it
still took me a long time
to build up the courage and it also took
some things happening to me at smith
where they really pushed me over the
line
um and they made it unacceptable um so
that i had to file a complaint so it was
a combination of those things and that's
that's what i think we're really missing
and i think what helen pluck rose is
doing with counterweight is so spot-on
because she provides a community because
i think
most people on the le i'm talking mostly
on the left or
any really anybody um
who they they know something's wrong
but they're not really quite sure what
it is because they're like well this is
good though this is
you know i'm i'm anti-racist and you
know
i'm seeking racial justice that's good
thing that's what i want i mean
there's very few people who would argue
that that's not a good thing
and yet something about it doesn't feel
right but they're not sure and they're
told that that little voice is bad
so then you try to push it away and i
think the validation part like
being able to talk to other people and
establish that you're not crazy and
racist and you're not alone
is so critical to people building up
their moral courage
and right now it's very hard to find
each other
we don't have any like places the all
the
most the institution has been captured
on this on the left for sure they've
all been there's no like aside from
whispering in hallways
there's no like a meeting ground there's
no third space
and so that's why what helen's doing is
so brilliant because she has a community
of people where you can go in and it
takes a while it's not just
like you talk to somebody once you're
like oh i knew oh
okay i'm not crazy it's a process it's
like a deprogramming
pro like there's there's stages um
and i still notice even after started
making the videos i still had some like
thought stuff going on like this
internal policing and
um i still have that a little bit like i
gotta kind of be careful what i'm saying
and
and i can't decide if that was always
there if it's a result of this but
i know that i you people need the
validation and they need to know
other people who who are liberal that's
that's the other thing because
there's no trust for anyone on the right
they need it and that's why i made very
clear
my first liberal my first video that i'm
a lifelong liberal because i wanted
people to know that i am
also a liberal if you're watching this
and you're liberal and this is
this is not good and jody doesn't it
doesn't it make you upset what's
happened to the left because
i once considered myself to be on the
left and you know the the
like i was a school teacher everybody
who regularly watches it drinks you know
i devoted 12 years of my life to working
with underprivileged kids that's what i
did
and the moment you come out and
criticize you know
you're all right and you just think
there's something deeply wrong
with that political side of the argument
if this is what we're descending into
yeah i know i'm really concerned i think
there's
i think we've been wait to cheer up mate
jesus christ i think there's this
dehumanization process like i said like
where it's just totally okay to be i
mean there's no
there's such little empathy involved
because we're not focusing on individual
people anymore
now we see the danger of moving away
from the individual and categorizing
people by groups because then they don't
become
they they kind of lose their humanity
they become like a herd or a mob instead
of
instead of a person and then it becomes
easy to just
be mean and write them off and do things
that have real material consequences for
their life such as
in the what happened at smith college on
july 31 2018
uh it's it it really
concerns me a lot um and i think it
concerns you guys a lot too
you're right to be concerned because i
know that you speak from personal
experience about smith college
but actually what you're describing is
in all probability happening on almost
every college campus
in the united states and to some extent
in the united kingdom and in many other
parts of the west so it's not
an isolated incident this is one of the
things that would be great for people
to take away from this conversation this
isn't just the thing that happened to
you
this is happening everywhere and at
every college there's someone in your
former position waiting to speak out and
you know you talk about
people being encouraged and emboldened
by you know
understanding that they're not alone
that's why we were so keen to have you
on the show because i think
this won't end until people like you
are given the opportunity to reach an
audience
and the until people like you land on
their feet
because let's talk about the fact that
you've resigned
and you refused their settlement which
was
requiring you to speak to stay silent
and not speak about this is that correct
um they offered me a settlement yeah i
mean
it's not unusual for a settlement to
require a non-disclosure agreement
sure and and why would would that be
a sort of admission of culpability on
their part to some extent or not
i don't know i i don't know the
legalities of that
i don't mean legally i mean you're you
do you think that they were just
you were sort of a nuisance or they
genuinely recognized that if you
continued to pursue
your complaints it would lead somewhere
i don't know it's hard for me to
speculate because
i mean any number of things could it
could be happening like maybe they
they suspected i would file a claim and
they didn't want me to do that
they didn't want just not because
necessarily they thought they would lose
but just because they didn't want to
have the expense
of that or maybe they don't want the
publicity anymore
i mean there's any no and why didn't you
accept the settlement because you need
money right
yeah that was ah that was really hard um
a numb i talked to a lot of people that
week a number of
factors went into my decision making um
and then it came down to a dream in the
end but uh
i didn't want to be in a position where
if somebody else at smith college for
example
managed to screw up went through the
same process i did man or
or else something happened to them and
they were forced to be public
that i would not be able to speak up and
support them even if i was no longer at
the college
i did not want to be in that position um
so that was one thing i also
i don't see a whole lot of other um
complaints on the horizon um there's a
complaint in nevada right in the state
of nevada right now
gabrielle clark is suing a charter
school her and her
son for similar similar stuff
um she's actually black and her son is
is half black but he has blue
blonde hair and blue eyes so um he was
made to talk about his white privilege i
believe um [ __ ]
me yeah jesus christ
um so she's suing she's she's very brave
she's standing up and she's suing the
school
and i i'm just con was concerned that if
i disappear
i mean this is how how they do it i mean
anytime somebody gets up
they you know somebody has very little
money like me or
anybody you know any other lower level
worker
um it's like i would
you know for not
that much i mean in my case it well i
don't want to talk too much about the
the settlement negotiations
um but
if you can't talk about something
then you you can't do anything about it
and even though i would be able to talk
about it in general i just felt like it
was
really important that i'd be able to
continue to speak out about smith and
that i
not give up any potential legal claims
um because i don't see i had thought i
really thought about this i thought well
maybe like
other people will bring claims and i can
just take the settlement and just
have be comfortable and be okay i mean i
was so exhausted
by this point like so incredibly
exhausted and it would it would have
been
so great and i thought maybe other
people will
you know fight this and i was like but
what if they don't
you know like i thought i'm going to
make this video and all these other
people at smith are going to stand up
well
no all the people i'd been whispering to
in the in the hallways all disappeared
like they evaporated and i thought oh my
gosh they don't want to be associated
with me i thought
i'm going to create this movement at
smith college and that didn't happen
and i mean it happened more on a
national level which was great
but i thought geez people are
like and i understand it i was like
this this could be it
i i mean i don't know i just didn't want
to give up
in the end and what and then i had a
dream and i woke up and i thought oh i
understand it's comfort or freedom
the freedom to keep discussing this and
possibly having
and no income and huge legal fees
um or comfort no legal fees and
total comfort for a while um
and i chose freedom and i i really
i made a video about that i really
stepped off a cliff because i had no
idea
i knew i had some support already from
the video and i thought well surely
people
will will help me fund this but i didn't
know if they would
and so i was taking a huge leap of faith
and i i was it was kind of very jordan
peterson asked like just tell the truth
and trust just do the right thing and
trust that
it will work out and so that's really
what happened
um and so far so good
so far so good hey constantine
yeah are you tired of all those typical
meditation techniques that leave your
masculinity
wanting more yeah i've tried them all
mindfulness zen
transcendental and i still feel like my
life is lacking
well maybe you should try marty's minute
meditations mean it meditation is that
pun
yes it is that's right with the comedic
and mystical
marty's minute meditations podcast
we can all discover how to save our
sacred masculine
from our toxic modern selves i swear to
god i prefer advertising b days
the podcast is available from wherever
you get your podcast
and you can also visit the website
minute www.marty'sminutemenit that's
marty's minute
meditations.com might as well get a b
there while you're there
and what advice jody would you give to
people who are in a similar situation to
you
who are experiencing the same things who
have got their own struggles with this
yeah i i think i say
the first thing to do is find at least
one other person and maybe already have
one other person
um but so if you have one other person
that you can talk to about this
honestly honestly and that gets it
and that you can continue to talk to on
a regular basis to work
it out because you're gonna have doubts
they creep back in you're like well
maybe i am racist
or maybe i like you gotta work that
stuff out it takes a while
and then if you already have one person
find one other person and now you have a
group
now you have three people and then you
need some kind of infrastructure
um so like a facebook page or you know
private one
um or a discord server even better
because that's more private some way to
gather more people and i i've said this
before and i
realized what i'm what i'm actually
giving the blueprint for is a grassroots
movement
um but i think on a pers so that's more
of a broader political thing
or a broader mobilization but on a
personal level
i think it's really important to have
somebody you can talk to about this
because otherwise it will if you are
alone
dealing with this in your head it is it
is
it can drive you crazy it can really
that's my experience and that's my
experience talking to other people who
are struggling with this too that it's
just
relentless physical symptoms
can't sleep it's just it it's just
really
and i've been reading about people from
the soviet union too like um
i actually posted a quote that it drove
some people crazy
and some people committed suicide
is that well true it was true and uh
actually the other thing is and i'm sure
they'll start doing this in the west as
soon as they possibly can
they would put people into mental
institutions for challenging
the the soviet narrative so if you don't
if you don't subscribe to the idea that
you know
you're racist well that's a sign of
mental illness let's stick you in a
mental hospital
uh and you know as i say i'm sure we'll
we'll get there very soon
um but thanks mate yeah well you'll be
you'll be the first one in there
with my support frankly but uh you know
it's
it's a weird one uh but you talk about
the soviet union
and you mentioned jordan peterson this
is one of the things that he often
quotes
when he's talking about the importance
of telling the truth he's actually
quoting solzhenitsyn
who who talked about the fact that every
time you tell a lie
a part of you dies yeah
yeah and every time you you listen to a
lie and you don't
challenge it a part of you dies and very
quickly
if everyone does that you'll very
quickly end up in a society where
everyone is lying to each other all the
time and i think
i'm sensing that that is really what you
came up against your own
unwillingness to lie repeatedly over and
over
yeah some yeah sometimes i think it's
there were many times when i thought it
was defective like there are many you
know my mom was like
i don't understand it like nobody else
has a problem with it just go along with
it you know and
i don't know what it is about me that i
think
maybe it's my artistic background or you
know and i'm an introvert
and i i don't know but i do think
other people feel it i i don't think
it's just me
um oh they do feel it yeah i think they
feel it yeah
yeah of course they do and that's why
people watch you know they watch our
show and they go
thank you for keeping me sane this last
year because for many people it's the
only place they get to hear a different
a different set of views that are based
much more in fact and statistics and
research and whatever and you can have
a sensible conversation about is there
racism is there structural inequality
and and there is some truth to all of
these things there is
a kernel of truth uh that has now been
inflated into a larger thing
uh that has taken on a life of its own
and as you said
it makes it difficult to have actual
conversations about the actual issue
when you're forced to subscribe to these
completely false narratives
yes which which then makes it impossible
to address the issue
right to address the problems when you
cannot
um talk about the problems in an honest
manner
um part of the problem
in talking to each other is that this
ideology
is is that we we have certain tools that
we use
in western society it's called
enlightenment values that we use to
determine
what is true you know we've logic reason
evidence the scientific method you know
we have agreed
it's kind of implicitly as a society
that we're going to use these tools and
so when we
talk to each other we say well i think
this
and here's why here's my evidence and
here's my argument
and the other person says well this is
what i disagree with you and here's why
and then
and then you assess each other's
arguments based on the evidence and the
logic and the reason
right well this ideology
would have us believe that those
tools in and of themselves are
tools of white supremacy and therefore
are not valid
and so that makes it impossible for us
to even have a converse to even
determine
we're not even using the same tools so
let alone have this using the same
definitions of words that's already gone
too but if we cannot even agree on what
tools we're going to use to have the
discussions then we can't have a
discussion at all
um and then you know you immediately get
written off based on who you are
you know like oh i didn't like that book
well why not because the author is
x color and has no right right writing
it it's like well what about the book
like was it good you know
so that's that's the problem that's
that's a major problem i see
in keeping us from uh
being able to talk about things and as
you know that's how we make social
progress we we talk it's into if
intellectual freedom and in in freedom
of speech
and jodi are there any regrets for
the course of action that you took is
there not a part of you that looks back
at your former life where
you unfortunately had to keep your mouth
shut but you were at least comfortable
etc etc you mean is there a time in my
life where i kept my mouth shut and was
comfortable
comfortable or no do do you is there a
part of you
the regret standing up for
what you believed in no
no in fact uh
although i had some doubts when i made
the video
uh there was a big huge sense of relief
i thought i'm out i mean it must feel
like
people may i think about um you know
my a relative of mine was a gay
man and he
was not out for most of his life you
know older
and he came out when he was close to 70
and he lived you know life he had a wife
and
and he was so happy when he came out and
i just think wow like all those years i
mean he didn't talk about it but i
thought
that must have been really tough
and um so i think as with anyone
living who's living a lie or lying
trying to lie themselves or convince
themselves that they're not
actually what they really are it there's
a huge relief in finally admitting that
and being very public about it like this
is who i am
like and then letting the chips fall and
yeah and for me it really was a decision
of um
the damage that was being caught that i
was feeling
be by not saying anything became greater
than what i imagined
the potential damage would be from
coming out
and so not a small moment just before
you're about to publish a video where
you thought
if i cross a rubicon
i can't remember to be honest with you
um no i was pretty
determined by that point kind of a lot
has happened since then
jody listen uh before we ask you our
last question uh tell everybody how
they can where they can follow you
online if they can support you in any
way
uh we really would like people to show
the support and keep in touch with you
and follow what you're doing
oh yeah um so i have a website where i'm
now collecting everything it's
jodyshaw.net jodyshot.net
and then of course there's the gofundme
which
is now over the amount i had originally
hoped to collect and
anything extra let's keep it going
because that those are going into
an escrow or trust i'm not sure i need
to talk to a lawyer but um
to help other people who
are in these kinds of environments and
i want to give them a better choice than
signing the nda for like
you know a little comfort versus being
able to take legal action or keep
talking about it i just want to
give people a better choice than that
and i think that's a big barrier to
people standing up is they don't have
money for a lawyer um so it's legal fees
for people that want to do that
so that's just go gofundme it's like
help jody with live legal and living
expenses but it says on there what
over 150 is going to go to um we'll put
the link in the description
uh which leads us to our final question
dirty which is what do you think is the
one thing that we as a society
are not talking about that we actually
should be
oh um
i feel like i'm supposed to come up with
something really brilliant here
no okay no the best move for you in this
situation would be just to be with a
straight face go
toxic whiteness
i think we should be talking about um
i'm going to go with the honest route i
think we need to be
concerning ourselves very quickly with
developing some
mental health tools to um
if this thing turns around which i hope
it will
and if it doesn't even but we're going
to need some help
because there's going to be a lot of
mental health
issues i think unfortunately from this
kind of thing and i'm really worried
about that for people
and also i think we should be talking
more about how
middle-aged white women are perfectly
capable
of doing a a very amazing rap
[Laughter]
i'll get that to the top of the agenda
someday
uh jody uh thanks for coming on the show
yeah and
yeah thank you for watching guys uh
please check out our episodes
they always go out on wednesday and
sunday 7 p.m uk time
and most importantly go follow jody
online and support her fundraiser
we'll see you again very soon take care
good night
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below